[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to the Disney live-action remake
month Disney likes profitable phases
doesn't it don't get me wrong some of
the most timeless characters have made
money for years but they also like to
focus on what's popular for the moment
whether it be Disney Channel Original
Movies DVD sequels are buying what you
thought for a second wasn't theirs they
finally ask the question what if they
combined their timeless story still
making money with their search for fad
still making money and with less
creative effort hey they had to continue
those timeless stories that already made
the money what if they just told them
again
now we're talking the Disney live-action
remakes for the most part have turned in
a huge profit so much so that the time
this video is released at least twelve
other Disney stories are in the process
of being remade
it's a Groundhog Day except instead of
you becoming a better person the world
is becoming continually worse and one of
the earliest hits was Maleficent
[Music]
starring Angelina Jolie this was
supposed to do for the villain of
Sleeping Beauty what wicked did for the
villain of The Wizard of Oz hey Disney
is ripping itself off enough why not
steal from other sources
the idea of telling a fairy tale from a
different point of view is nothing
different but the advertising for this
movie made it look like you were going
to be rooting for the bad guy like oh it
feels so good to be so bad let's look
for that antihero and seeing how
Maleficent is easily one of Disney's
best villains this could kind of be cool
what we got is not cool
is it possible though that just like to
leave this is all a misunderstanding and
I should look closer to find something
of worth do all crows secretly have a
cool stylin emo studmuffin inside of
them stay cool boy let's take a look at
Maleficent lets us tell an old story in
you and we will see how well you know it
well if you're telling it anew we can't
know it the first line is literally a
lie so there's a kingdom of people and
the kingdom of creatures the Navi
refused to eat as a young Maleficent
shown here is taxidermy owl wings on an
American Girl doll is one of the kindest
and gentlest of all faeries
I guess they regret calling her
Maleficent then I should tell this time
a piece of it next time fine
thank you I hope you're laughing your
ass off at this because there's 20
minutes of this joy sprinkled all
throughout the film for what delivering
a bad punchline or looking like a CG
Barbie dolls Barbie dolls Christ are
those ugly they find a farm boy named
Stefan who stole a jewel from them but
Maleficent forces him to give it back
she walks him back to his kingdom where
he reveals his parents are dead
my horns ripped up my mother's insides
at birth and then I head-butted my
father on the way out they agreed to
form a friendship over the years and
even end up loving each other she throws
up in danger Lina Jolie a fitting choice
as she's a mix of beautiful and kind of
funny-looking
but as you'll see the writing does
little to keep her an interesting
character for several years pass and
Stefan was away taking asshole lessons
so he could help the King destroy the
fairies because what was the reason
again crush them make sense
Maleficent is the protector of her
kingdom with her Treebeard army and
heads up nothing in the film is cooler
than the scene it's a great climax in
the first 15 minutes of the film set the
rest of the flick to Stefan the Crown's
personal Scottish Michael Bay here's the
King say whoever kills Maleficent will
become the future ruler of the land hey
how is the old M gal anyway Maleficent
he finds he can't actually kill her but
he decides to cut off her wings as proof
good thing Maleficent's a heavy sleeper
because she didn't even notice and she
wakes up d feathered never even got to
find out how they taste it
Stefan drops off the wings which equals
a body I guess and disappointed king
Maleficent says if one character can
spontaneously turn into a dick so can i
and she turns herself evil her first
order of evil business turned a random
crow into a boy
you monster I need you to be my wings
what's my coin ba ba what did I call you
ba ba it's not name that's the son of
goose mix when it farts fever so
Maleficent at ba ba decide to turn their
kingdom into a den of evil or just make
things dark but do it look so evil and
hatch the diabolical plan of sitting
around and doing nothing for years dot
your evil no no starting point of course
Stefan gets himself a queen who gives
birth to a daughter named Aurora and
three of the other kingdoms most
annoying fairies come to foster peace I
[Music]
may see in grief and sorrow and other
people confuse you so you cannot comfort
them before the last fairy can give her
present though by the way yes we never
figure out what it was going to be
maleficent steps into customly show off
that she has two rows of teeth I'll call
you in a 90s rain forest nice
patronizing before the Sun set
Sahn her 16th birthday she will prick
her finger on the spindle
oh that's much worse actually won't you
just make a death why a deep sleep
that's like that one you just make it
Devlin that'd be a lot too simple your
curse and because this movie's tone also
seems to be on a spinning wheel listen
to the music they play over this scene I
like you begging do it again oh yeah
she's totally cursing that baby oh yeah
thank you oh the princess can be woken
from her death sleep but only by true
love's kiss no what are the chances a
beautiful girl who's happy 24/7 will
find someone to love her monster so yes
if the fairies weren't pointless enough
in this they don't even offset
Maleficent's magic with true love's kiss
or sleep instead of death edition yeah
don't you remember that was the last
gift that the fairy was supposed to give
but now there's just no gift at all it's
just Maleficent's own idiotic curse that
was a lot simpler in the original it's
on my 16th birthday she shall prick her
finger and die oh wait wait there's also
like 5 loopholes I myself wanted to put
it I want to be a Faris of evil to make
things even dumber it's the King's idea
to give his daughter to the fairies to
raise her for 16 years why they in no
way show they have an understanding of
maleficents magic and they act like
bumbling dumbasses look at their faces
they can barely even carry this kid one
song of rockabyebaby can turn into
rock-a-bye baby scarred so Maleficent
builds a wall around her Kingdom don't
worry the humans will pay for it
and
in the sorrow that her curse had brought
and the millions of ways it can be
overturned like I haven't done the math
but I'm pretty sure it's in the mills
the ferries go to a cottage where they
do eventually make themselves bigger oh
how fake can we go back to the realistic
looking CGI bodies and as expected they
turn out to be pretty shitty parents
right down to leaving her outside to be
spotted and Maleficent finding them
literally before they could even move in
there goes all that suspense oh wait I
take it back there actually is a lot of
suspense suspense that these three
lobotomize hocus-pocus stooges will kill
the child before Maleficent dies in fact
Maleficent saves Aurora from they're
benign child slaughtering ways and even
ends up raising her more than the
fairies do I'm not even joking that's
what happens over all these years
look I'm open to a different
interpretation but the fairies in the
original were clumsy but loving and
caring and charming these three
literally let the baby almost die on
several occasions and sleep through half
of it and fight through the other half
their despicably unlikable in fact
they're easier to hate than the
character you're supposed to hate
actually yeah let's talk about her for a
bit it's clear what Disney's trying to
do they're trying to go the wicked route
of taking a famous villain with no
sympathy and making her a misunderstood
hero but here's the thing the original
Wicked Witch from The Wizard of Oz is a
thug she's a simpleton with a low
vocabulary who uses blunt force to get
whatever she wants there supposed to be
no charm to her
so in wicked it's compelling when you
see her as the opposite a smart fragile
charismatic yet misunderstood outcast
who got blamed for everything because
she was different and didn't always know
how to fight back you can easily see how
this world would make up a story about
her being this villain with Sleeping
Beauty Maleficent is already a charming
charismatic and sophisticated villain
she has her outbursts of course but
there's always a charm and grace to
whatever she does you love how smart
elegant and diabolical she can be so to
make this work you would have to do the
opposite and a I'm not sure that's what
this movie does and B if it does it
doesn't do it well
she's not simple in the Taffet charming
naivete but she's also not intelligent
enough to be diabolical or menacing her
actions half the time are pulling pranks
on the fairies or trying to scare the
baby with faces and when it doesn't work
she says like a fifth grader so uh no
level does this come together it can't
go all the way with what it originally
was but it can't go all the way with the
opposite either she's the badass
mistress of all cuter I'm so behind her
being a badass villain except when
they're trying to make her cute awkward
babysitter mistress of all evil how
about mistress of just stopping home
alone sequels in our spare time though
that would be a welcome gift
[Applause]
[Music]
so as the years pass Aurora now played
by Ellie Fanning grows older and
wouldn't you know it Maleficent and
heard for a close friendship again this
film really gives us exactly what we
want from a Maleficent movie I know
you're my fairy godmother to be fair I'd
rather have heard it Helena Bonham
Carter
so she visits Maleficent every night and
they just hang out throw mud at each
other have Girl Talk express their
feelings
again exactly what you would want from a
Maleficent movie did I mention in the
upcoming Frollo film that him and
Quasimodo go bowling it's very sweet and
totally understands the character and
effect she gets along solo with her or
that she even tries lifting the curse
but she finds she can't yeah apparently
even she doesn't know what the hell her
powers can do there is an evil in this
one
i frolicked and smiled like nobody's
business I'm very self-reliant lucky
lucky though a young prince named
Phillip is wandering through the forest
and comes across Aurora it's love at
first goodbye the small talk hey it's no
more dialog than they had the original
film thus Maleficent at Bev ah discuss
if the prince can break the spell true
love's kiss remember I can break the
spell true love's kiss I cursed her that
way because there is no such thing it's
a very abstract open to interpretation
spell so on the eve of her 16th birthday
Aurora tells the fairies that she's
leaving them we'd add to the mood and
they accidentally blurt out who she
really is we are taking you back to your
father you told who my parents were dead
it's almost like you're awful awful
awful awful awful awful people
Aurora clarifies this with a real parent
Maleficent did you hear how stupid that
sounded that's the story and she also
discovers that Maleficent is the one who
cursed her don't touch me no the evil is
in the world no actually that's the good
version but this one is at least dumb
she makes her way to her real father who
has slowly been growing insane over the
years resulting in his voice and even
sillier that did before just like him
all those three idiots they brought you
back a day to sit lock her up in her did
they replace him with a shrinking
scrooge mcduck how am I supposed to be
intimidated by that voice maleficent
thinks the princes kiss might work so
she knocks him out and tries taking him
to the palace where Aurora is she of
course pricks her finger and goes into a
deep sleep throwing her father's voice
into a gargling rage look out look at
what you've done
she's only sleeping oh my god have they
been too pesticide yet where's your
bedside manners she's only sleeping
she's only sleeping forever David
Tennant's sucking helium balloons would
sound more intimidating than this guy
the prince tries kissing her but it
doesn't work so Maleficent goes in and
don't get too excited it's the frozen
logic the love for a family member over
a romantic love and since the spell
already has enough fine print it
accounts however the crazy old white
dude reveals he's the villain and not
the scary looking green lady because
again if we're not gonna tell this story
we might as well tell this one and the
guards and trap her what she turns them
off into a dragon I feel like there's
several instances where that could have
come in handy I need you to be my wings
turn yourself into something with wings
why can't you Richard ah an Aurora
breaks open Maleficent's wings that fly
directly to her yeah a Sleeping Beauty
teamed up with Maleficent to fight an
old crazy guy sorry no part of that is
cooler than this even an acknowledgment
to their past relationship or the years
of love that they share she just tosses
him over and it's done you kind of even
forgot they were in love it's such a
meaningless connection they have but at
least the scene later it's revealed that
Aurora is now queen of both kingdoms all
those years of giggling and twirling in
her dress will no doubt lead to a strong
government so you see the story is not
quite as returned even though Disney
told me the first version I ever heard
and I liked it a lot better and I said
no what I was the one
Sleeping Beauty I've been smoking a lot
that's why my pitch is a little off my
kingdom was United not by a hero or a
villain but by one who was both hero and
villain so that way nobody is happy so
that is one of the greatest Disney
villains of all time doesn't it show
I'll admit it does look very nice even
though the effects can be very fake it's
still a shot quite beautifully and gives
us some nice visual landscapes but this
movie is an insult to one of Disney's
greatest characters we don't want to see
Maleficent as a hero we love her fine as
a villain if you want to make her more
complex fine but don't tell us deep down
she's a good person that's not what
we're looking for some villains are
still good we enjoy hating them like the
Joker a Freddy Krueger or any number of
the Disney baddies trying to people bed
and good ruins what we appreciate about
this kind of character to begin with
that she did go all the way
there's definitely great villains that
can explore the good and the bad but
this shouldn't be one of them this movie
needed to pick a side a tone and an idea
to stick with instead it just sucks out
the evil fund that made our happily ever
after all the more happier and it's a
spell I'm not gonna fall for and I'll
tell you what I'm avoiding the movies of
this writer I mean it's not like this
person wrote any other live-action
Disney feel it's the next one isn't
[Music]
[Applause]
you
fever
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing
campfire helping youth become who they
want to be takes time and encouragement
at campfire
they help youth discover the exceptional
people they honor campfire provides the
opportunity to find their spark and lift
their voice with 54 councils nationwide
last year they served more than 175,000
youths and teens their families and
community members across 1300 program
sites in 25 states the research-based
thrive ology framework helps your kids
and teens succeed right now if you look
at their site and their YouTube channel
you can see all the young people they're
inspiring giving lessons to and shaping
to make the world a stronger place check
out the link below and see how you can
spark a fire in somebody's life
[Music]
you